among the thousands fleeing Putin's
Russia many Dan show their face on
camera for good reason but in the
shadows at night some are prepared to
talk and are determined to say how they
feel
from the Gloom we're approached by a
Russian military veteran he has fought
for his country and served for four
years he says but is fleeing Russia
before he's called up
I really don't understand why I should
go this is not our territory the fact
they are trying to mobilize this many
people means it's start of something
very serious yes I have some friends who
are in Ukraine and France who came back
but they are not saying anything good
about it he is left in a hurry not least
because of where he's from one of the
Russian federation's Republics we're
being told that over the Border there
there are many young men from Dagestan
ingashettia chechnya and other North
Caucasian republics who are desperate to
leave because they believe that Vladimir
Putin's mobilization order is
deliberately targeting Russia's ethnic
minorities
[Applause]
that suspicion has fueled Fierce
protests in Russia's far-flung Republics
in the day since Putin's call up
security forces have crushed dissent
with Force
to verify what's going on in these areas
but at the border we met one man from
chechnya who says young men there are
now urgently trying to get out
I have to Putin announce the partial
mobilization the mood of younger
chechens worsened everybody is trying as
fast as they can to leave Chechen
territory fearing they will be mobilized
those who cannot flee he says and are
forced to fight will not make good
soldiers I don't think they will try
hard because many of us think that this
is not our war and that Russia is an
aggressor
[Applause]
no war these women chanted police in
Dagestan
[Applause]
this man is from there and it just
crossed the border the situation was
getting worse he said because police
suppress ganging men into the army
Vladimir Putin is doubling down on his
wall but it's provoking widespread
unrest and a mass Exodus and raising a
fighting force of dubious quality
Dominic wagorn Sky News on Russia's
border with Georgia